bonjour monsieur ziad baroud merci
d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
vous avez très certainement entendu
comme nous la déclaration d' emmanuel
macron à propos de ce qui se passe en ce
moment au liban votre réaction par
rapport justement déclarations du
président français
écoutez ce que le président français
demande est déjà le premier set en se
recoupent entièrement avec ce que les
libanais souhaite voir appliquer comme
réformes et la mise en place d'un
gouvernement de mission et dans
l'intérêt bien compris de tous là les
libanais ne peuvent plus continuer à
gérer leur quotidien
de la même façon avec laquelle ils ont
mal géré je réussis dire pendant de très
longues années et pratiquement là
l'initiative française est une
initiative qui qui va dans l'intérêt des
libanais de tous les libanais c'est la
france et la ce est le seul pays qui
parle à tout le monde c'est la seule
initiative sur le plan national régional
et international et du coup il est dans
l'intérêt de tous de débloquer la
situation
or la trahison collective dont monsieur
macron a parlé est une est une réalité
c'est les bâtons dans les roues
c'est tout le monde qui les met
pratiquement à des degrés différents il
est certain mais on ne voit pas vraiment
suffisamment de volonté politique pour
aller vers une concrétisation de
de toutes ces de l'accord entre
guillemets de l'accord du 1er septembre
qu'est ce qui peut être fait aujourd'hui
justement pour que la situation soit
moins compliqué que que les politiques
comme vous qu'on vous le dit arrête de
se mettre des bâtons dans les roues
écoutez le problème des désintérêt des
uns des autres fait que pratiquement le
gouvernement n'ait pas eu là n'a pas vu
le jour
le premier ministre désigné qui s'est
récusé l'a bien dit donc à partir de là
il est dans ces c'est la responsabilité
de tous surtout ceux qui ont le pouvoir
d'empêcher les choses de d'arrivée
d'empêcher que la situation se normalise
aujourd'hui un gouvernement c'est
d'abord le fmi donc c'est le ministre
des finances pour justement que les
bailleurs de fonds puisse avoir un
accord avec avec le gouvernement
libanais c'est l'électricité du divan
donc c'est pas vraiment un changement de
régime c'est pas un changement radical
c'est une gestion de crise d'où
l'appellation de gouvernement de mission
c'est un gouvernement dont la mission
est très bien défini pour une sortie de
crise pour six mois et un an afin que
les choses soient mis sur les rails en
attendant oui tout le monde sait que les
élections américaines sont au menu
le report de l'initiative ou le mettons
l'extension de l'initiative pour quatre
à six semaines
cela coïncide avec les élections
américaines début novembre est donc
peut-être quelque part il y aura un
déblocage ou normes et entre temps la
crise économique et alors la sécurité
commence nous sentons une sécurité de
moins en moins
/ et là c'est inquiétant parce que s'il
n'y a pas de gouvernement s'il n'y a pas
des responsables capables de gérer la
situation
nous risquons d'aller vers le pire vous
visiez à l'instant zeyad baroud où
justement pas de gouvernement donc très
compliqué de prendre des décisions en ce
moment pour mettre fin à la crise au
liban
est-ce qu'il existerait des solutions
justement pour pour apaiser cette crise
sans gouvernement très difficile très
difficile déjà que a qu'avec un
gouvernement
les choses ne sont pas ne sont pas
évident que ce reste sans gouvernement
les partis politiques les forces
politiques qui sont qui essaye de rester
au niveau du gouvernement qui sont
représentées toutes et tous au niveau du
parlement
c'est c'est ce sont ces forces
politiques qui peuvent rendre les choses
enfin moins difficile il est certain
qu'avec la situation économique et
sociale surtout nous allons vers une
sécurité presque sûrs et du coup lèche
les choses ne sont pas que politique
le lait les grands les grands défis
c'est au niveau social ces au niveau
sécuritaire et il est important de
former un gouvernement le plus tôt
possible
quatre à six semaines je crois que c'est
déjà beaucoup
c'est déjà très loin je ne sais pas si
le liban et les libanais peuvent tenir
autant avec la situation économique
financière et sociale qui prévaut est
très rapidement avant de se quitter
ziad baroud est ce qu'un nouveau premier
ministre pourra réussir là où stafa adib
a échoué ce n'est pas tant la personne
du premier ministre désigné qui peut
permettre un échec en faire une réussite
à succès world ou un échec
mustapha adib en tant que personne est
quelqu'un de très respectable c'est pas
lui qui a échoué c'est ce sont les
forces politiques qui l'ont empêché de
former un gouvernement donc ces noeuds
ce n'est pas tant la personne du premier
ministre que la conjoncture que la
décision de tout
d'aller vers une déblocage de la
situation ou non merci beaucoup ziyad
baroud d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
sur rtl france rappelle et que vous êtes
ancien ministre de l'intérieur du liban
merci beaucoup